اهلا بكم الى النشره مفصله من العربيه انا
ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه مشاهدينا
نبدا بالعناوين
مقتلوا والي غرب درفوري يؤججوا الصراع في
السودان اتهامات متبادله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
وزير الدفاع الامريكي يؤكد عزم بلاده
مواصله دعم اوكرانيا حتى تحقيق النصر على
روسيا
اتفاق امريكي ايراني وشيك بواسطه عمانيه
يشمل الافراج عن سجناء امريكيين واموال
ايرانيه
وبعد توقفها لسنوات الاعلان عن تسيير
رحلات الحجاج مباشره من صنعاء الى جده
والمدينه
اذا مشاهدينا الشهر الثالث من الصراع في
السودان بدا مع اتهام التحالف السوداني
والذي كان يراسه الوالي خميس عبد الله ابو
بكر لقوات الدعم السريع بقتل الوالي في
مدينه الجنينه التحالف السوداني استنكر
السلوك الذي وصفه بانه يتنافى مع المواثيق
الدوليه في التعامل مع الاسرى من جانبه
قال حسن ابراهيم فضل وهو نائب امين
الاعلام في حركه العدل والمساواه
السودانيه ان ميليشيات مسلحه قتلت والي
غرب دارفور خميس بكر في المدينه بولايه
غربي دارفور وفي تفاصيل الحادث اقتحمت
ميليشيات مسلحه مقر اقامه والي غرب دارفور
الجنرال خميس بكر واختطفته وذهبت به الى
جهه مجهوله حركه العدل والمساواه دانت
عمليات القتل الواسعه ونهب الممتلكات
ممتلكات المدنيين العزل وتشريدهم على اساس
الهويه والعرق وحرق القرى وتدمير
المستشفيات والمؤسسات الخدميه خلال الايام
الماضيه في غ رب دارفور
[موسيقى]
في المقابل اصدرت قوات الدعم السريع بيانا
دانت فيه مقتل والي غرب دارفور الدعم
السريع قالت في بيان ان من وصفتهم
بالمتفلتين قاموا باغتياله على خلفيه
الصراع القبل المحتدم بالولايه اقرت قوات
الدعم السريع في بيانها بان والي غرب
دارفور كان تحت حمايتها لكن المتفلتين
بحسب وصفها هاجموه باعداد كبيره واغتلوه
بدم بارد قوات الدعم السريع وفقا لبيانها
اتهمت استخبارات الجيش السوداني بتاجيج
الصراع القبلي في غرب دارفور وما ترتب على
ذلك من موجات نزوح ولجوء
الى ذلك وصف حزب الامه القومي السوداني
اختطاف وتصفيه والي غرب دارفور بانه سلوك
اجرامي وتطور خطير في الصراع حزب الامه
حذر من ان التداعيات المتسارعه لاستمرار
الحرب ستجر البلاد الى وضع كارثي غير
مسبوق الحزب دعا الى انقاذ البلاد ببناء
جبهه وطنيه مدنيه لايقاف الحرب واستعاده
الامن والسلام
البعثه الامينيه في السودان دانت من جهتها
اغتيال الوالي وقالت في بيان لها ان هناك
افادات مقنعه لشهود عيان تنسب مقتل الوالي
الى ميليشيات وقوات الدعم السريع اضافت
انها لن تتجاهل الجرائم والانتهاكات التي
ارتكبت خلال الصراع في السودان او
ستقوم بتمريرها دون مساءله حثة البعثه
الامميه في السودان على الوقف الفوري
لجميع العمليات العسكريه في دارفور من اجل
تهدئه الوضع والتصدي للعنف العرقي
المتزايد
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نتوجه الان مباشره الى نيويورك
وهذه الجلسه لمجلس الامن حول السودان
رئاسه مجلس الامن لشهر الحالي واشكر السيد
رئيس لجنه العقوبات على تقريره ربع السنوي
سيدات والساده
الاثر الاقليمي للاحداث
بالرغم من ان القرار 15 واحد وتسعين منحصر
على اقليم دارفور ولكن اذا اعتبر ان
الاحداث الاخيره
وتدفقات النازحين ذات اثر متعدي فاننا نرى
التالي لم تتاثر علاقات السودان مع جيرانه
بسبب الاوضاع الانسانيه وان كان لكل
اشتباكات عسكريه اثار سلبيه بالضروره
ولم يتلقى السودان اجعارا بان النازحين
واللاجئين الذين وصلوا حدود بعض الدول قد
تسببوا في افلات الامن القومي
هناك محاولات لتهريب اسلحه نوعيه من شاكلت
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات لدعم التمرد ولكن
القوات الامنيه السودانيه تراقب ذلك
باسرار
ان معظم الدول
التزمت الحياد الايجابي لا سيما ان تشاد
اغلقت الحدود لمنع تسرب قوات التمرد الى
اراضيها واعتقلت الذين نفذوا اليها واخطرت
السودان بذلك هناك تقارير بتورط ومشاركه
لبعض فصائل المعارضه التشاديه مع قوات
التمرد ونشكر الحكومه الشاديه على تعاونها
في هذا المجال
وفيما يخص اوضاع اللاجئين السودانيين في
تشاد وبالتحديد في معسكرات والداي سيلا
واديفيرا ان الحكومه التشاديه تؤكد
تضامنها مع السودان حيث يبلغ تعداد
اللاجئين السودانيين الذين نزحوا اليها
بعد الانتهاكات التي اقترفها اقترفتها
الميليشيا 113 الف في الولايات الثلاث
ويلقون ترحيبا من المجتمعات المحليه
العائدون منهم حوالي 25 الفا ومعظمهم من
النساء والاطفال وفيما يتعلق بالحدود
الشماليه الغربيه للسودان قد تشهد ايصال
مساعدات مثل تموينات القتال مناصره لقوات
التمرد
واما بشان الحدود مع افريقيا الوسطى فهي
مفتوحه وهادئه ولكن هناك مساء من قبل قوات
التمرد الاستغلالها
كما ساوضح
حدودنا مع جمهوريه مصر العربيه هادئه
ومفتوحه وقد استقبلت مصر
الالاف من المواطنين عقب الاحداث الحاليه
ونشكر القياده والشعب المصري على ذلك على
الحدود الاثيوبيه الامن مستتب ولا يوجد ما
يشير الى تاثر امنها القومي بفعل الاحداث
وفتحت ابوابها لاستقبال اللاجئين مع قله
الاعداد التي وصلت الى هناك ولقد اشارت
بعد الوفود بالمجلس في جلسه في جلسه سابقه
الى احتمال تدهور العلاقات بين السودان
وجنوب السودان بفعل عوده اللاجئين
الجنوبيين الا ان ذلك لم يحدث المعلومات
التي تلقيناها من اوضاع اللاجئين من جنوب
السودان
بمحليه الجبلين الحدوديه تشير الى استضافه
الولايه لاكثر من 365 الف لاجئ
منهم حوالي 220 الف وصلوا الى المنطقه من
الخرطوم بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره واستقروا
في معسكرات محليه وذلك وفقا لاخر احصائيه
رسميه اجريت في العاشر من شهر مايو الماضي
وفيما يخص الوضعيه الانسانيه في اقليم
دارفور فقد تم توزيع كميات كبيره من
المساعدات الانسانيه والصحيه من قبل
برنامج الغذاء العالمي في مناطق وسط
دارفور وشمال وغرب جبل مره ومججار وام دخن
وادي صالح وزالينجه وفي جنوب دارفور في
مناطق النياله وكاس وجريده وبلال وفي جنوب
كردفان في ابو جبيهه وابو كرشوله وديلامي
والدلنج والليري وجدير وكادوقلي ورشاد
وثالودي وفي وسط دارفور بلغ عدد
المستفيدين من الاغاثه الانسانيه 101 الف
شخص 617 وفي شرق دارفول
وفي شرق دارفور بلغ عددهم 33 الف وميه
وعشرين شخص وفي شمال دارفور بلغ عددهم
143,946 وفي جنوب دارفور بلغ عددهم 89,769
وفيما يخص الوضعيه الانسانيه الراهنه في
وسط وغرب وشرق دارفور اي مثلث الجنينه
زالينجي ونيالا ان اعتداءات ميليشياء
الميليشيا المتمرده على القوات المسلحه
واعتداءات الميليشيات المتحالفه معها على
السكان في ولايات دارفور لاسيما في مدينه
الجنينه حاضره ولايه غربي دارفور افرزت
واقعا انسانيه رهيبا حيث يجري استهداف
المدنيين بالهويه وتم تدمير البنيات
التحتيه اللازمه لتوفير الخدمات الاساسيه
ان هذا الواقع يتطلب استجابه انسانيه
عاجله وفي هذا السرد نعرب على الشكر
والتقدير لكافه الدول الشقيقه والصديقه
والمنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه والحكوميه
وغير الحكوميه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
المحليه والاجنبيه التي استجابت للنداء
الانساني الذي اطلقته حكومه السودان
وساهمت في تقديم المساعدات بصفه عاجله
الامر الذي كان له اثر كبير في تخفيف حده
الازمه الان والاستجابه للطوارئ لكن ذلك
يتطلب المزيد خاصه في ولايه غرب دارفور
التي شهدت احداثا جساما يؤسفني ان ابلغ
مجلسكم الموقر ان الميليشيات
المسنود بقوات من الدعم السريع اعتقلت
واختطفت والي ولايه غرب دارفور الاستاذ
خميس عبدالله بكر يوم امس ثم قامت بقتله
والتبشيع بجسمانه جدير بالذكر ان الاستاذ
خميس يمثل احد الاطراف الموقعه على
اتفاقيه جبل السلام ونترحم على روحه وهو
التزم موقف الحياه اسوه بغيره من اطراف
التي وقعت على اتفاقيه
ان الحكومه السودانيه تؤكد التزامها
بتسهيل دخول وحركه العاملين في الحقل
الانساني ومنحهم تاشيرات الدخول والتصاريح
اللازمه وتامين سلامتهم لاداء مهمهم
الانسانيه على الوجه المطلوب كذلك ستواصل
في تسهيل الاجراءات الخاصه
بدخول المساعدات من الموانئ والمطارات
وامكانيه نقلها وتوزيعها وفقا لخارطه
الاحتياجات لكل الولايات المتاثره بالازمه
ونشدد على ضروره ممارسه اقصى درجات الضغط
على القوات المتمرده المتحالفه معها من
اجل وقفي جرائمها واعتدائها والزامها
بتسهيل المسارات الانسانيه وعدم التعرض
لقوافل المساعدات الانسانيه وازاله مظاهر
الوجود العسكري في مناطق التجمعات السكنيه
والخدميه
وفيما يخص وضعيه القرار 15 واحد وتسعين
لقد ذكرنا في مرات سابقه للمجلس ان القرار
15 واحد وتسعين قساهم في اضعاف هيبه وحضور
الدوله في اقليم دارفور وفي الحفاظ على
الامن وحمايه المدنيين بسبب الحظر المفروض
على السلاح على القوات المسلحه مما ادى
الى ترجيح كفه المجموعات المسلحه وتقييد
جهود الحكومه في حفظ الامن ونعتقد بان عدم
توفر الدعم المالي والوفاء بتعهدات
المجتمع الدولي لدعم عمليات نزع السلاح
والتسريح
واعاده الدمج لمقاتل الحركات المسلحه
واطراف اتفاقيه جبه قد اثر ايضا على تنفيذ
الاتفاقيه بطريقه مرضيه وان تواجد قوات
التمرد في اقليم دارفور وهم مدججين
بالسلاح مدعاه للقلق
فقد ثبت مشاركه عناصر اجنبيه في تركيبه
مقاتلي الميليشيا ومنهم من جهر باخذ
فيديوهات خلال مشاركتهم في القتال مع
العثور على اسلحه متقدمه وذكيه تم تسريبها
الى معسكر طيبه الخاص بقوات الميليشيا عثر
عثر عليها في حاويات محصنه تحت الارض
السيد الرئيسه ان العنف المشتمل على النهب
الواسع النطاق وحرق المساكن والمرافق
العامه والمؤسسات الحكوميه وتدمير البنى
التحتيه والاسواق والمدارس والمستشفيات
ومخازن الادويه هي كلها جرائم ارتكبتها
الميليشيات وهناك ايضا استهداف للمواقع
العسكريه التابعه للقوات المسلحه في
دارفور اضافه الى استهداف مطارات وجسور في
حاله
ان نمط جرائم الميليشيا تكرر بنفس الوتيره
لهدم الدوله السودانيه في المركز والهامش
وذلك بالطواطئ
مع جهات سيتم الكشف عنها في وقت لاحق هذا
العنصر لا بد من الاشاره اليه في التقارير
الامميه لان الحياده امام جرائم فرقه الى
مرتبه جرائم الحرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
يعتبر تشجيعا للاستمرار في ارتكاب هذه
الفظائع ان اللاجئين الذين وفدوا الى تشاد
كان سبب نزوهم يعزى لهجمات الميليشيا
المبرمجه لافراق المكون الديموغرافي ووضع
اليد على الارض بمثل ما فعلته بانتهاك
حرمه الملكيه وحق الحياه ووضع السكان في
ظروف معيشيه فضه وهذا يندرج تحت طائله
القانون الدولي ان الفجوه الامنيه التي
ادت الى تفاقم الاشتباكات القبليه في
دارفور وما اسفرت عنه من المواجهات ما كان
ذلك ليحدث لو تم القاء القرار 15 91
المتطاول الامد الذي عمل على اضعاف القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ودورها في حمايه
المواطنين في دارفور لدرجه ان الميليشيا
استهدفت القوه المشتركه
المكونه بين تشاد والسودان واستهدفت قبائل
بعينها من قبل ميليشيا واستهدفت قبائل
بعينها من قبل الميليشيا لدرجه ان
المليشيا منعت حتى ادلاء الجرحى والمصابين
بعد ان دمرت المستشفيات وان الميليشيا
وحلفائها كانوا يقتحمون البيوتات بابا تلو
باب مع قوائم معده سلفا للمستهدفين ان
الجرائم المرتكبه في الخرطوم ودارفور
واستهداف وتقتيل سكان
تهديف السكان خلال حرب خلال الحرب الراهنه
انما تكرر الان في سيناريو انما تكرر الان
في سيناريو القتل على الهويه الاثنيه
وفيما يتعلق بالسلامه الاهلي
نطلب في هذا السياق من الامم المتحده دعم
جهود السلام الاهلي بموازات جهود الرسميه
التي تبذلها حكومه السودان هناك جهود
اهليه اخرى تقوم بها منظمات المجتمع
المدني من اجل تهدئه الاوضاع ومعالجه
الاثار الحرب في هذا الاطار وقعت المكونات
المدنيه بولايه جنوب دارفور وثيقه عقد
اجتماعي وتراضي مجتمعي ضمت
80 قبيله بالولايه وذلك ضمن جهود المبادره
المجتمعيه بالولايه لوقف الحرب واعاده
الحياه المدنيه
ولمعالجه الاوضاع بمدينه جنينه وولايه غرب
دارفور انعقد اجتماع طارئ ضم حاكم اقليم
دارفور مع ولايه مع ولاه ولايات دارفور
حيث سيقوم الولاه او قام الولاه برئاسه
حاكم الاقليم بزاره الى الجنينه حاضره
ولايه غرب دارفور باستصحاب المتطوعين
برئاسه من الكوادر الطبيه والادارات
الاهليه والمنظمات الوطنيه والمبادرون
للوقوف ميدانيا على الاوضاع الامنيه
والانسانيه والعمل مع سلطات الولايه لنزع
فتيل
الازمه واستدباب الامن وتحقيق السلام بعد
الاحداث الدمويه التي شهدتها الولايه على
مدار الايام الماضيه كما تم ارسال الادويه
والمواد الايوائيه الموجوده ببورسودان عبر
مطاريها الفاشر ونيالا لتوزيعه على
المتضررين اضافه الى تامين كل الطرق
الداخليه والقوميه منه الى دارفور وهذا ما
يستدعي ان تكون الاولويه لعمليات بناء
السلام وتوفير دعم اللازم لترسيها خلال
المرحله القادمه والنوعيه لبعث
السيده الرئيسه ان قوات الميليشيا تعمل
الان على محاصره منطقه امدافوك الحدوديه
بين افريقيا الوسطى
والسودان وهذا
قبل حلول موسم الخريف بهدف نشر اليات لها
هناك وهذا العنصر مدعاه للقلق حيث سيترجم
الى سلسله من الهجمات النوعيه التي تستهدف
القتل على الهويه ونحن نحذر من ان عدم
ادانه هذه العمليات سوف يخلق غول يهدد
الامن من الخرطوم الى الساحل وهذا سيتحمله
صمت المجتمع الدولي عن ادانه هذه الاحداث
النابيه واننا نلاحظ ان هناك محاولات لربط
جنوب ليبيا مع منطقه ام دافوك بهدف نقل
اليات حربيه لدعم المجهود الحربي لقوات
المليشيا
اما فيما يتعلق بوحده مكافحه العنف ضد
المراه والطفل ان عناصر الميليشيا
وتحرشاتها ضد النساء ادت الى ارتفاع مستوى
حالات العنف الجنسي المتصل بالنزاع في
الخرطوم ولم ترد اي تحديثات بشان اقليم
دارفور ان الميليشيات تمارس جرائم الخطف
وتطالب بدفع فديه ماليه كبيره ان
الميليشيات استهدفت اي دبلوماسي او سفير
سوداني ادلى بتصريح ضدها اجتهدفت بيت
ونهبت ممتلكاته ان وحده مكافحه العهد ضد
المراه والطفل تشير الى زياده جرائم الخطف
والعنف الجنسي الجماعي في الخرطوم والتي
تستهدف صغيرات السن من الفتيات وفي غالب
تلك الجرائم اكدت اصابع الاتهام الى قوات
ترتدي زي الدعم السريع وفقا لافادات
الشهود وان هذه الوحده تقوم بتوثيق هذه
الجرائم بهدف انهاء الافلات من العقاب
اشكركم على حسن الاستماع شكرا سيد الرئيس
لم يعد هناك اسماء مدرجه على قائمه
المتحدثين رفعت الجلسه
ايضا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى كلمه المندوب
السوداني في مجلس الامن جلسه مخصصه حول
السودان والتطورات هناك احاطه ان كان من
الجانب الانساني او الميداني وكانت هناك
اتهامات مباشره لدعم السريع ان كان في
عمليات النهب بصوره عامه وايضا العنف
الجنسي وغيره من الخروقات اضافه الى قضيه
تصفيه والي غرب دارفور طبعا مشاهدينا بهذا
الاطار كان هناك مناشده بان لا يكون هناك
حياد بهذا الاطار واي حياد اعتبره المندوب
يعتبر مشاركه وتشجيع لهذه الجريمه ويعتبر
جريمه بحد ذاته على كل للمزيد معنا من
القاهره الصحه في السودان عبد الله الشيخ
ومعنا ايضا من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي
الباشا محمد اطباق اهلا بك باشا ابدا معك
خاصه فيما يتعلق بتصفيه والي غرب دارفور
دعنا نتحدث عن هذه الحادثه من المستفيد من
تصفيه هذا الرجل ما الذي يمثله
مع التحيه لك يا استاذنا وتحيه لمشاهدي
قناه
العربي به المقلوب على الامر الان حقيقه
ندعيني اولا اتحدث عن المندوب الذي تحدث
باسم السودان اريد ان اوصل للمجتمع الدولي
وللامم المتحده ان هنالك ليست حكومه
سودانيه العاشر شرعيه معترف بها مش راح
ندخل بشرعيه مين خلينا نقفز عن هذه النقطه
مع الباشا اسمح لي مش موضوعنا مش موضوعنا
من يحظى بالشرعيه من عدمه خلينا نركز عما
حدث على الارض الدعم السريع متهم مباشره
بانه وراء هذه التصفيه تفضل
واؤكد لك تماما ان الدعم السريع وقياده
الدعم السريع لها علاقه ممتازه جدا مع
والي ولايه غربي دارفور رئيس التحالف
السوداني وقائد الدعم
قبل ان
الوجبه الثوريه حتى اصبح عضوا في في تحالف
الجبهه الثوريه ووقعت يعني من ضمن من ضمن
الموقعيين الاتفاقيه سلام باشا محمد بس
اسمحلي
صحيح
الباشا الباشا محمد
نعم قبل ان تقفز حول العلاقه ما بين
الطرفين يعني بالبيان رغم انه الدعم
السريع قال لا علاقه له بعمليه التصفيه
الا انه اشار الا ان هذا الرجل هو جزء مما
يحدث على الارض قام بتسليح اتباعه المدعوم
من قبل الجيش الا يعتبر بذلك عدو بالنسبه
لها على الاقل في الوقت الراهن
الى دعا المواطنين الى حمل السلاح هو
البرهان هو البرهان الذي الان يقود هذه
الحرب البرهان هو من دعى المواطنين يعني
بحمله السلاح لحمايه انفسهم ومن كسر مخزن
السلاح في مدينه الجنينه وسلح به
المواطنين هو الذي يتحمل هذه المسؤوليه
الدعم السريع واكد لك تماما ليست له اي
مصلحه في اقدام
له مصلحه وهو الجيش السوداني هو هي
الاستخبارات التي تزرع الفتنه بين
المواطنين وهي التي تقاتل الى جانب اسميه
محدده
طيب دعنا ندخل السيد عبد الله الشيخ
لقراءه المشهد طبعا تتابع من القاهره هذه
التصريحات الكل يتهم او كل جهه تتهم الجهه
الاخرى بانها المسؤوله عن ذلك انت من خلال
متابعتك من هو المستفيد ولماذا يمكن للدعم
السريع وهو يسيطر على تلك المنطقه يعني
تعتبر تحت حمايته ان يقوم بمثل هذا العمل
الذي يعتبر جزء من جرائم الحرب
في الحقيقه هذا هو استمرار
لعمليه التنصل التنصل عن الجرائم التي
تقترف وهذا هو ديدا
الاحوال في السودان طيله العهد الماضي
وطيله هذه السنوات العجاف التي يمر بها
السودان كل الدلائل التي طرحت تشير الى ان
الدعم السريع متورط تماما في هذه المقتله
والدليل على ذلك
والدليل على ذلك هو البيان الذي صدر من
الدعم السريع نفسه اضافه الى ان الكلمات
التي قالها
[موسيقى]
مندوب السودان في الامم المتحده هي كلمات
دقيقه من وجهه نظري حيث انه يقول ان
الميليشيات التي
تتلقى الدعم من الدعم السريع هي التي فعلت
ذلك وهذا هو يعني
هناك هناك من يتحدث انه لا يمكن للدعم
السريع ان تقوم بذلك كل ما يحدث على الارض
هو بدء هذا الشرخ فيما يتعلق بالعنف
القبلي كيف يمكن لنا ان نفصل هذا من ذاك
وخاصه انه التصريحات التي تعتمد عليها في
مجلس الامن من المندوب السوداني اشارت
ايضا الى العنف القبلي
صحيح العنف القبلي ولكن هذا العنف القبلي
له ارتباط بما يدور في الساحه السودانيه
في الخرطوم تحديدا نحن نرى ان قوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم تلقى ضربات عنيفه جدا
او هي بلا هدف داخل الخرطوم لاسباب كثيره
جدا وهي ليست بذات العنفوان الذي كانت
تدير به المعارك في بدايه العهد في بدايه
العهد من قبل شهرين يعني وبالتالي هذه
الميليشيات
تحاول ان تمهد المسرح في دارفور حتى تعتلي
القوات الدعم السريع ومن حالفها المسرح في
دارفور
وتجعله متكا وحاضر لها اذا ما انكسرت
الخرطوم وهذا امر وارد بالمناسبه
لذلك
هذا العنف القبلي الذي تتحدثين عنه تحاول
قوات الدعم السريع ان يكون على حساب قبيله
المساليد تحديدا لهذه المنطقه الجغرافيه
وفي مركزها في الجنينه
ندخل السيد الباشا حول هذه النقطه
والتعليق عليها
باشا محمد من مصلحه الدعم السريع ان تسيطر
الان على تلك المنطقه بصوره كامله وان
تقسي اي شخص ممكن ان يقف حد امامها وحتى
لو لم تقم بعمليه التصفيه هل يعني ذلك
بانها كما حدث في الخرطوم في العاصمه فهي
ايضا في غرب دارفور لم تستطع ان تسيطر على
رجالاتها ربما على الارض او تسيطر على
المنطقه
في عملياته في المنطقه التي اشعل فيها
البرهان الحرفي هي الخرطوم الدعم الشريعه
الان ليس مركزا على على ولايه غربي دارفور
او اي ولايه من ولا موجوده على الدعم
السريع الان قضيته الاساسيه هي الطعم التي
تقود القوات المسلحه في القرطوم البرهان
وزمرته فليس له اي تركيز الان في ولايه
غربي دارفور او غيرها
عليك تحرك تحرك من الادارات الاهليه
بمنطقه الغربي دارفور لاخبات هذه الفتنه
لكن ابدا الايدي الخبيثه الا وان تصير هذه
الفتن بكسر مخزن السلاح الذي كسرته قوات
نظاميه لتسليح جزء من القبايل وايضا يعني
هنالك القوات الجيش التي تجمع للبور هي
تقاتل خلف او مع يعني قبائل يعني بعينها
للاشتعال هذه الفتن هذه الفتن كلها هي من
صنيعه البرهان وجمرته يا اختي الكريمه
الدعم السريع لجنه مصلحه يعني
اهميه قصوى لدعم الدعم الخرطوم
رغم ما اشير انه هناك شهود عيان وقالت انه
هناك من يرتدي زي الدعم السريع قاموا بمثل
هذه العمليه على كل ننتظر ربما التحقيقات
من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي الباشا محمد
اطباق شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفي من
القاهره الصحفي السوداني عبد الله الشيخ
على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
لتطويق الصين في المحيط الهادئ باب وغينيا
الجديده تسمح للجيش الامريكي باستخدام
قواعدها العسكريه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه جدد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه في اجتماعي وزراء الدفاع
شمال الاطلسي بروكسيل القول بان واشنطن
مستمره في دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه حتى
تتمكن من استعاده سيادتها واراضيها اوستن
اكد ان الاداره الامريكيه ستواصل امداد
الجيش الاوكراني بالاسلحه والذخيره وبكل
الامكانات الضروريه وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
اشار الى ان طموحات روسيا تسببت في معاناه
الشعب الاوكراني بشكل لا مثيل له اوستن
كشف عن الخطط التي تم وضعها لتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه ولتعزيز قدراتها على القتال
منذ ان بوتين حملته العسكريه ضد اوكرانيا
قبل اكثر من عام كان يعتقد انه سيحقق
الانتصار بسهوله لكنه كان مخطئا لقد حرر
الاوكرانيون خاركي وخرسون واليوم تقف
اوكرانيا بقوه امام حد اخر الولايات
المتحده فخوره بوقوفها ومعها 50 دوله في
دعم اوكرانيا وتقديم المساعدات والتدريبات
العسكريه التي حققت نتائج جيده في المعارك
لقد اثبتت القوات الاوكرانيه كفاءه عاليه
في القتال
قال وزير الخارجيه العمانيه بدر البوسعيدي
ان ايران والولايات المتحده
تقتربان من وضع اللمسات النهائيه على
اتفاق بشان اطلاق سراح امريكيين محتجزين
في طهران الوزير العماني اشار الى ان
المساله تنحصر في امور فنيه فقط واوضح ان
ايران كان لديها شروط اولها الافراج عن
اصول ايرانيه
بمليارات الدولارات مجمده في بنوك كوريه
جنوبيه بسبب عقوبات امريكيه
فصل جديد في المسار الشائكي للعلاقات
الامريكيه الايرانيه هذه المره تتجه
الامور نحو تفاهم هادئ عبر الوسيط العماني
عنوان هذا التفاهم المال مقابل السجناء
فيما الهدف الاكثر الحاحا للامريكيين هو
تجنب كارثه في الموضوع النووي
الطرفان لم يلتقي وجها لوجه بحسب مجموعه
من الصحف الامريكيه لكن الوسيط العماني
يتوقع نتيجه سريعه لا سيما فيما يتعلق
بالسجناء الامريكيين المحتجزين في ايران
استطيع القول انهم قريبون المساله تنحصر
في امور فنيه هم بحاجه الى وضع اطار زمني
بشان كيفيه تنسيق ذلك مكاسب الاتفاق تبدو
مناسبه للطرفين في الظرف الحالي امريكا
تستعد مواطنيها السجناء الذين تحولوا الى
نقطه التوتر الاساسيه بين البلدين ايران
تحصل على مليارات الدولارات المجمده خصوصا
في مصارف كوريا الجنوبيه ويعود الملف
النووي الى مسار التهدئه بعد خروج عمليات
التخصيب عن السيطره الاتفاق المتوقع ياتي
في اطار مشهد اقليمي متغير هذا المشهد
يهيمن عليه من جهه الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني برعايه صينيه ومن جهه اخرى مخاوف
اسرائيل المستمره ازاء ايران وتاكيد رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو عدم الالتزام باي
اتفاق بين واشنطن وطهران
في اطار الجهود واشنطن لتطويق الصين في
المحيط الهادئ طبعا بموجب اتفاق امني
تاريخي سيكون الجيش الامريكي قادر على
تطوير وتشغيل قواعد في ببواغينا الجديده
النص الكامل للاتفاق عرض على برلمان بابو
غينيا الجديده مما سمح بكشف تفاصيل
الاتفاق الذي وقع في مايو الماضي وبقي
سريا
وبموافقه الجديده سيكون بامكان الولايات
المتحده نشر قوات وسفن في المطارات
الرئيسيه
قال منسق السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان الشعب السوري
عانى من مستويات الفقر القياسيه التي نجمت
عن اكثر من عقد من الصراع وان 90% من
السوريين يعيشون تحت خط الفقر مطالبا
العمل بشكل ايجابي من اجل حل الازمه
السوريه نتابع
الشعب السوري واللاجئون السوريون عانوا من
مستويات الفقر التي نجمت عن اكثر من عقد
من الصراع منذ عام اجتمعنا في هذا المنتدى
كان عاما مؤلما شهد زلزالا مدمرا وجلب
المزيد من المعاناه للسوريين وبالفعل يعيش
90% من السوريين في الداخل تحت خط الفقر
وستون في المئه يعانون من انعدام الامن
الغذائي ولا يعرفون من اين ستاتي وجبتهم
التاليه من غير مقبول ان تكون سوريه في
هذا الوضع ولن نتسامح مع الازمه الحاليه
التي يعيشها الشعب السوري مهمتنا ايجاد
الطرق للعمل بشكل ايجابي من اجل حل الازمه
ومهمتنا اليوم ان نجلب الامل للشعب السوري
فاصل ونواصل الخامسه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه دواء اوزنبيك
لانقاص الوزن منذ اشهر والدواء يتصدر
محركات البحث وترند على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ياتي هذا بعد ان اثنى مشاهير
على مفعوله الذي وصفوه بالسحري وقد شارك
مؤثر تيك توك تجاربهم المذهله معه اشاده
ادت الى اقبال شديد على المنتج والى
فقدانه من الاسواق دعونا نتابع من يفكر
بانقاص وزنه فبالتاكيد صادفه الحديث عن
هذا الدواء
منتج طبي مخصص لمرضى السكري شهد اقبالا
جنونيا بحثا عن التنحيف ما ادى الى فقدانه
من الاسواق واثاره قلق الاطباء
للدواء السحري بدائل كدواء مونجارو مثلا
لكن البديل الذي يثير اكبر ضجه الان هو
البديل الطبيعي الارخص والمتاح بسهوله في
الصيدليات وهو البربراين او المعروف
بنيتشر اوزنبك هكذا يقول الاطباء
البربروين يعتبره الباحثون مساعدا مكملا
لعلاج حالات مثل تعديل ضغط الدم ومقاومه
الانسولين وتنظيم الكوليسترول فهو مركب
كيميائي مستخرج من نباتات مثل خاتم الذهب
والبربريس عاده يباعك مكمل غذائي في
كبسولات مليئه بمسحوق اصفر اللون
تم استخدام المركب في اسيا منذ اكثر من
2000 سنه وصار علاجا للشكاوى والمعديه
والمعويه وبحسب تاكيدات الخبراء فانه قادر
بالفعل على انقاص الوزن لا بل انه يحقق
نتائج اكثر ضمانا من اوزمبك الذي لا تزال
فعاليته مسار جدل وكونه منتجا فعالا بحسب
الاطباء فهذا لا يغني عن بعض الاثار
الجانبيه الموثقه كالغثيان وارتفاع ضغط
الدم وارتعاش اليدين والقدمين بالاضافه
لتقلصات في الرحم لدى الحوامل
البربراعين بشكل عام مركب امن هكذا تشير
الدراسات لكن الخوف هو من تسويقه دون
ضوابط
المزيد ينضم الينا من عمان دكتور انس
اليزوري وهو استشاري علاج السمنه والجراحه
العامه اهلا بك دكتور انس خليني ابدا
بصوره عامه بالحديث عن هذه الادويه خيار
الان خاصه انه كنا في السابق اهلا بك
نتحدث عن ان كان الحميه الطبيعيه طبعا
ترافقها الرياضه او ان كان عمليات تصغير
المعده
نعم الان هو
المركب المنسؤول عنه اللي هو الاوزنبيك
الاوزومبيك هو عباره عن
دواء انتاج اللي هي علاج السكري من النوع
الثاني وهو اسم العلمي
وهو نوع من انواع او جروب العام له اللي
هو الجلوكاجون هذا الدواء وجد لعلاج
السكري من النوع الثاني لكن وجد انه تاثير
على انقاص الوزن لاسباب معينه اللي منها
هو يقلل من يحجم من وظيفه الكبد في انتاج
الجلوكوز يزيد من
الانسولين في الدم وهذا اللي بساعد على
نزول الوزن بالاضافه انه ببطئ من عمليه
انتقال الطعام من المعده الى الامعاء
بالاضافه
الى يعني دكتور انس معلي اسمح لي يعني
الادويه هاي تساعد على انقاص الوزن ولكن
هل بالنسبه لكم دكاتره هي خيار اصبحت الان
افضل من الخيارات الطبيعيه التي ذكرتها
قبل قليل انا
لتاثيرها بضلوا محدود اختي يعني في افضل
يعني مراحلها او افضل حالاتها ما بتنزل
اكثر من عشره بالميه من الوزن هي تفضل
للناس اللي عندهم الكتله اقل من 30 وهي
كتله هي مؤشر بين الوزن والطول بتساعدنا
على اختيار اجراء المناسب هلا استخدام هذا
الدواء بطريقه غير يعني على على هواء كل
مريض بدون اشراف طبيب كجراح سني او جراح
او عفوا طبيب غدد صماء هذا خطا لانه في له
اثار جانبيه وفي له مضاعفات
نعم هو سهل استخدام
انس لانه البعض يقول انه تفضل
في له اثار جانبيه يعني من اثار الجانبيه
مثلا انه هي اثر قليله الحدوث لكن منها
التهاب البنكرياس او هبوط السكر في الدم
بالاضافه انه ممكن ياثر على الانسان
يزيد ما عنده من حاله الغثيان الاستفراغ
التقيؤ عنده في له اثار جانبيه الافضل انه
يكون تحت اشراف طبيب جراح سمنه او طبيب
باطني اللي هو الغدد والسكري
من عمان الدكتور انس اليزوري واستشاري
علاج السمنه والجراحه العامه شكرا جزيلا
لك
كشف وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر الارياني ان
الخطوط الجويه سوف تدشن يوم السبت اولى
رحلاتها لنقل الحجاج من صنعاء لجده
والمدينه مؤكدا ان نقل الحجاج اليمنيين من
صنعاء جاء بتوجيهات من الرئيس اليمني
وتعاون السعوديه من جانبها اعلنت وزاره
الحج والعمره السعوديه عن تيسير رحلات
الحجاج اليمنيين القادمين لاداء فريضه
الحاج لهذا العام لاداء العمره
[موسيقى]
نبقى في اخبار الحاج حيث يتوجه
3,600 شخص من بريطانيا الى السعوديه لاداء
شعائر الحج هذا العام الزميل مصطفى زارو
التقى ثلاثه من حجاج بريطانيا دعونا نتابع
محمد هلال ومحمد الشوزري ومحمد امين ثلاثه
اصدقاء من اصل بنغالي ذاهبون رفقه ازواجهم
لاداء فريضه الحج قلق رفقهم خلال عمليه
التسجيل حتى تاكيد حجزهم لخوض هذه الرحله
الايمانيه
لاول مره مع زوجتي وهذا من فضل الله تعالى
بوابه الكترونيه اعتمدتها وزاره الحج
والعمره لتطوير التجربه الرقميه لضيوف
الرحمن من اوروبا وامريكا واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا بدءا من تسجيل عمليه الترشح
والقبول الى اختيار باقه الحج من الشركات
النظاميه ضمن الجهود المبذوله لتسهيل
الاجراءات
محظوظ من يستطيع حج بيت الحرم وسط ازمه
غلاء المعيشه ومحظوظ اكثر على من يحصل على
احد الاماكن المحدوده المخصصه للراغبين في
الحج من بريطانيا هذا العام الحمد لله
انا جدا محظوظ كما تعرف اكثر من 20 الف
شخص يذهبون الى الحج من بريطانيا والعدد
الان تم تقليصه الى قرابه اربعه الاف شخص
انا جدا متحمس ومحظوظ لخوض هذه الرحله
الروحانيه
الكثير تغير وانا متحمس لتجربه هذا النظام
الجديد للحج وانوي اداء مناسك الحج بقدر
المستطاع على افضل وجه
هؤلاء الاصدقاء الثلاثه استكملوا جميع
متطلبات السفر الى مكه والمدينه تلقوا
الارشادات الوقائيه والنصائح اللازمه
اثناء اداء شعائر ومناسك الحج وحزموا
حقائبهم للانضمام الى الحجاج من كافه
انحاء العالم مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
المكسيك محطه ثانيه لروائع الموسيقى
السعوديه العاصمه المكسيكيه شهدت ليلى
فنيه سعوديه خالده نتابع بعضا منها في هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
روائع الموسيقى السعوديه
مبادره ثقافيه تحط رحالها في مكسيكو سيتي
ثاني العواصم الغربيه بعد ليله فارسيه
ناجحه اواخر العام الماضي شهد التالق
الاوركسترا الوطنيه والكره للسعودي باعمال
من ابرز الاغنيات السعوديه
المبادره السعوديه التي اطلقتها هيئه
الموسيقى لفتت الانظار مجددا هذه المره
بمشاركه اوركسترا كارلوس شافيز المكسيكيه
وعشرات العازفين والفنانين السعوديين
[موسيقى]
لوحه موسيقيه تعكس ثراء الالوان الموسيقيه
في المملكه من الالحان الى الرقصات
الشعبيه التي ادتها فرق هيئه المسرح
والفنون الادائيه في المملكه بالوان
مختلفه كالخباتي واليمنبعاوي والسامري
والرايح والخطوه
[موسيقى]
باداء الفنانين السعوديين احدى اشهر
الاغنيات المكسيكيه وهي سيليتو لاندو التي
تفاعل معها الجمهور المكسيكي بحفاوه بالغه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تاتي مبادره روائع الموسيقى برعايه مباشره
من وزير الثقافه الامير بدر بن فرحان لنقل
جماليات الموسيقى السعوديه
وتنوعها الممتد لعشرات السنين الى كافه
محبي الموسيقى حول العالم في امسيات تبرز
امكانيات موسيقيين السعوديين وتحتفي بارث
صناع ورموز الموسيقى في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامس الان شكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات